[Music]  did you miss me  hey what do you mean who am i it's  me and  it's finally ready a brand new game from  my company  check it out you get to control me  time to do this  look at me go quack rats  check out these chunks they came back  and  they have wonderful new talents  throw that stick thing not the bad  use the spinning what you might call it  nailed it same micro game  different abilities  i almost forgot some big news two people  can play together  at the same time so be nice  or else  not nice all right you yes you  the one watching this better get ready  for some micro game  mayhem  the warioware get it together game  launches exclusively on the nintendo  switch system september 10th  pre-orders begin today on nintendo eshop